look how white this is and my walls
aren't painted hi my name is grace
helbig if you do not know now you know
your life is different now I feel a
variety of things
I feel Pleasant I feel crazy I feel
terrible I feel wonderful I just got
back from two weeks out of town that
included trips to New York City London
and Dublin and I feel like I lived a
thousand lives in the last two weeks
each cats you know at nine it was a
whirlwind time but now I'm back in Los
Angeles and I am making this video for
you and you know what this is already
it's the end of November is a time for
some November favorites was that
pleasing let's jump right in yeah yes
yeah yes yes say yes when I was in New
York City I did a Sephora run and god I
love that little teaser zone that was my
failed gameshow title Ambika this
holiday season Sephora has even more
great stuff in that zone is this
tartlets tease wow I didn't know that
that's what this was called drink every
time she says tease don't that got
fetishy and weird real quick fun it is
not this is by tart and it's a little
eye shadow palette how outlet what do
you call what do you call it we call
recon outlet that what do you call an
outlet think it's upset and it doesn't
get its way up outlet wasn't worth it I
know I agree with you it's a cute little
travel eyeshadow palette that has a
bunch of like brownish neutral ish
colors and there's some matte colors and
there's some shimmery colors and I like
it very much
it's tiny compact and has all the pretty
shades that can make you pretty all
right the shallow societal standards
that I'm not above admitting I adhere to
because it makes me happy what a tease
next yeah yeah say yeah yeah say I can't
say it this has likely been in a
favorites video before as that sentence
has also been in a favorites video
before this is a blush from Stila it
looks like this oh that looks bright and
it is bright and I like it this is a
custom color blush a self-adjusting
coral what this blush claims
is that it will adjust to your skin
color tone whatever so it looks
different on everyone I don't know or
understand or care to really know or
understand the scientific witchcraft
behind it but I do know that I like the
way this blush looks on me so that's
cool
cue next now I mentioned in many
favorites videos that I love st. Tropez
self-tanning mousse gels all of it hey
here's my travel sized one here and this
was gonna be in the favorites video but
this has been in so many favorites video
so just know that I still continue to
like this I bought this in London at
Superdrug it is called seiche Rapace
instant tan wash off face and body
lotion it's basically like a
self-tanning makeup that you just kind
of put on your body and it tans you and
it doesn't transfer I use this my memory
and I went to the banca Awards and it
did not transfer Oh demo okay why not I
use my hands when I put this on but it
suggests that you use the mitt that the
here's the mitt this is covered in
self-tanner just so you know oh this is
fun okay so I just put some on this oh
anybody and it doesn't smell the worst
spreads super easily and it feels really
light and it says it takes like three
minutes to dry that it feel like a
[ __ ] Home Shopping Network post uh
who knew I was gonna cross something off
my bucket list in this video not me yeah
does that look different and you want to
drive for like three minutes and you're
good to like what goes on rub up against
people just grind just shoulder grind on
everyone that's what we're all here for
right that's shoulder grind yeah I like
it and it washes off with water just
like actual makeup next see ya see ya
can't see it this is a scent this has
been mentioned tacit question mark
there's no one here to give you answers
to this grace I love Elizabeth and James
Nirvana black it's what I wear all the
time but I was getting kind of bored
with it and then I found out that
Elizabeth and James have two new scents
ones rose and ones bourbon and I'm all
about that bourbon bout that bourbon
make it a double
this smells so good here I go trying to
describe scent it just smells good one
of the other things I bought in that TZ
danger zone of Sephora is there's only
Lizabeth and James kind of like gift
pack that has Nirvana white Nirvana
black
Nirvana bourbon and Nirvana rose in a
smaller little bottle for relatively
cheap that's a fun like gift to give
someone it's fun to give the gift that
insinuate that someone doesn't smell as
good as they could you know these shoes
are cute as [ __ ] also Kate Spade so I
got these in New York City on my way to
the bankers in London cuz when I got to
New York City I realized that I forgot
that I was going to the bankers and I
didn't pack a dress or shoes ha I got
them at DSW they were a little bit more
expensive than I wanted to pay for shoes
but they're really cute and so I'm
putting them in this video so I feel
like I got way more use out of them than
just the one minute the bunkers in which
I can't find a photo of myself from that
actually shows these shoes so I haven't
been able to Instagram them so I just
want you to know that I like these and
now my purchase is validated next this
is the purse I carried to the bong cos
I'm just favoriting everything that I
wore to the bunkers the dress I wore is
from Zara which I love and this purse is
from forever 21 can you believe it yeah
I can because I just heard a bead fall
right off of it forever 21 is dominating
all of the holiday stuff right now
so I thought I'd put this in this
favorites video just to give you a heads
up if that's something that you need or
are curious about anyway this purse was
like 20 bucks maybe less than that I
don't know but it looks like like my
great grandmother gave this to me yeah
she didn't give me anything except an
innate ability to repress my feelings
and never actually communicate cute next
can't see I can't see yet is these pants
okay I'll do a cutaway thing these pants
are from Zara I got them when I got my
dress for the bunkers and I love these
pants and you probably hate them and I
don't care I love them so much they're a
dropped crotch pinstripe pant that stops
at the ankle calf I mean could they be
more complicated and could they be more
a reflection of me in my current state I
wear these for like three days in a row
in New York City and I haven't washed
them and I put them straight back on
when I got back to LA it's not something
to brag about they're just so good
cute next oh let's put food in yeah
can't see yeah you can't see it and you
actually see it this is Boar's Head if
you're under that meat brand I didn't
realize how much I would love the words
meat and brand put next to each other
until right now
horse head solid meat brand these are
these little snack packs that they make
that have provolone cheese and
sopressata it's like salami ask type
meat thing this is basically just a
slightly more sophisticated lunchable
and I love it I have a lactose
sensitivity yes but provolone cheese
doesn't seem to mess me up and or I just
don't choose to recognize when it does
fun and they come with a bunch of
different combinations of stuff some of
them have these little like biscuit
things in them
treat yourself why don't you just got
sad okay that's it for November
favorites I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did hit this button right
here and subscribe to this YouTube
channel or give it a thumbs up so I can
quantify my choices and let me know what
you guys have been loving this month
also one of my favorite things this
month was um the London and Dublin
audiences that came to her this make it
weird girl shows thank you we had such
an amazing time I hope you guys did too
other than that I don't know I used this
a lot the last two weeks when travelling
clearly it's all washed off oh no oh my
god did I just I think a dry heaved and
burped and hiccup all the same time in
my mouth
Oh triple threat jealous I know you're
not